écoute on va faire une interview quand
on bosse à tête et pascal sellem quand
on bosse à tf1 est ce qu on dit à sa
famille à ses amis ses enfants non je
leur cash
on leur dit je suis désolée je suis bien
obligé de vivre des trucs comme ça je
leur dis que c'est grâce à tf1 qui sont
en train de manger de la viande un barca
et ont dit à ses enfants tu sais papa
est en train de réaliser son rêve quand
on bosse à tf1 et à ses enfants depuis
qu'il est rentré
est-ce que la continent préfère
s'asseoir entre bataille et fontaine ou
ppda est claire chazal
quand on bosse à tf1 mais si jamais
foutu les pieds à tf1 ah c'était bravo
c'est vrai je suis jamais allé dans
l'île même si j'y suis allé une fois
mais ils m'ont demandé ma carte
d'identité pour rentrer du coup je suis
pas ne suis pas allée tient encore une
carte quand on menaçait tf1 on a droit
de regarder d'autres chaînes pendant son
temps libre
bien sûr je regarde tout le temps
d'autres chaînes pendant mon père yves
pascal sérieusement quand on bosse
c'était parce qu'on est obligés de faire
des émissions et carole rousseau c'est
pas moi c'est laurent qui meurent
entraîné un obligé de téléphoner sur
bouygues telecom non non parce que des
fois quand on bosse et tf1 on aimerait
aller plus loin on aimerait aller
ailleurs on a toujours envie d'aller
ailleurs
1 quelle belle réplique par exemple
j'aimerais bien aller ailleurs aux
toilettes pas quand on bosse de chance
de rentrer deux s'étaient pas quand on
bosse était fort mois est ce qu'on prend
un bon paquet de thunes pascal
maintenant oui et avant c'était plus dur
mais maintenant oui et on laisse ses
enfants regarder way to tout c'est bien
je crois qu'il faut viser une carte à
discours je suis furieux parce que c'est
un poisson clown
non
absolument fois ça m'a pris deux heures
et demie pour avoir une carte non mais
en même temps j'étais sous la langue de
2,9 et du sacré bon travail je serai
demi pour avoir une carte à 37 secondes
et hop copinage en tout cas ça nous en
dvd les biens puis à plein plein plein
de bonus
ouais ya nice people et il est super
drôle dans son dvd il a fait quoi
elle a fait un truc super drôle non en
fait en effet le dirait je vais pas le
dire
ouais je crois qu'on peut on peut donner
le scoop il a un blog au jeu parce que
c'est en fait ça me sert pas trop normal
audi pas avant je ne dis pas non je vais
le dire en fait quand on met le dvd les
sept péchés capitaux dans son lecteur
la première image qui arrive c'est ce
dvd ne convient pas à votre lecteur 1 et
la 3 6 7 5 secondes après trois petits
points non j'déconne
et là il ya des gens qui ont déjà été
voir là
comment
mathieu
bien